so let me introduce Andrew mantel NT
who's the CTO and founder of parsley
which is startup doing working with
content publishers to provide them
analytics and more relevance to reach
their audience and also let me introduce
Keith Bergen he's the backend lead for
parsley so they'll be talking about real
time streams and logs I'm Python cool
can you guys hear me okay all right so
so yeah thanks for having us here this
is uh I think our third PI data now
we've been a PI date out on the East
Coast in New York a couple of times
before we're excited to talk to you
about some very new stuff real-time
streams and logs with Apache storm in
Kafka the agenda of our talk is to cover
a little bit about what we do at parsley
and why we use storm and Kafka and
production for our web analytics
platform talk a little bit about how you
can aggregate aggregate streams of data
using apache storm and particularly
using python with apache storm since
it's a JVM technology we've written some
code that helps with that and then Keith
will dive into Kafka and explain why
it's a good design principle to organize
data processing systems around blogs
some quick admin on this talk all of the
presentations in code that parsley has
given an open source are available at
parcel y / code so you can go there and
you can actually see the project links
that we're talking about today as well
as actually the web-based slides that
you're looking at right now so if you're
in the back and can't see things you
could pull it up on your browser we also
have a note form of the slides up there
and you can click on that link in order
to actually get more detailed info that
you can copy paste like code samples and
things like that so very quickly what is
parsley so parsley as the introduction
mentioned is a web analytics platform
for digital storytellers these are some
examples of our customers we work with
large-scale content publishers online
and they send us a lot of data that we
use in order to help their journalists
editors writers and site manager
understand how content is reacting with
audiences across the web we get a lot of
high-speed data the typical news story
you could imagine has a very short shelf
life typically less than 48 hours it's
fast moving its minute by minute second
by second time series data we get a lot
of volume of data thousands of posts per
day or published by our content
publishers and we've been tracking
millions of posts across the web in this
way and some different kinds of data
that we play within our platform include
time series summary data that might do
aggregates and grouping by different
categories ranked data and these are all
screenshots from our dashboard that I'm
just flying through so rank data that
might group content by different tags or
topics benchmark data that might compare
how the certain content has performed
relative to the past and then in general
we kind of refer to information
radiators that bring all this data
together real time streams historical
streams and showcase basically how
content is moving on their websites so
how did the architecture parsley evolve
over time well we started like almost
every distributed system engineering
team with a basic queues and workers
architecture so how many people here
have built accuse and workers
architecture like almost everyone here
right so like most people we started
with tools that are well-worn and
understood like RabbitMQ when we hit
scaling issues with those we move to
more lightweight queuing mechanisms like
Redis and zeromq and with workers we
started with the simplest possible which
is cron jobs that are doing certain you
know things in Python and then went up
from there to something like celery
which is a pretty nice worker system in
pythons community but what we found is
that over time things started to get
pretty complex and I'm sure you guys
have found this too if you've worked on
complex or large-scale data processing
pipelines you have a lot of workers
they're doing a lot of multistage
processing if anything breaks in the
chain you don't really know what
happened you start setting up ad hoc
systems that start communicating across
a lot of different boundaries and it
becomes difficult to debug what data
actually ended up in your database and
that data actually came from in terms of
its provenance starting in the queue and
also you just have lots of moving parts
so this is an actual diagram I drew a
couple years ago when I was trying to
understand the system we had wrought on
our servers right all of these workers
and q's operating on real-time streams
of data and it just gets really messy
and you you basically start developing
ops dashboards and spending most of your
time trying to manage systems rather
than actually building business logic
around the time series data you are
collecting in the first place so storm
is actually a framework that was
developed at back type a company
acquired by Twitter a couple years ago
and storms now an Apache project and
basically storm tries to solve this
workers in cuse problem by turning it
into a framework so it's a distributed
real-time computation system you can
kind of think of it at naga Slee to
Hadoop in the sense that Hadoop gives
you all these primitives for working
with batch processing well storm gives
you primitives for working with
real-time computation or stream
processing for running long running
processes that are operating on a
fast-moving stream of data rather than
in the case of a dupe something where
you might run batch processes across
like file system data sources and it's
perfect for a replacement for that messy
system I just kind of outlined on the
last slides storms features are that
it's fast it can handle millions of
tuples per second per node it's got
fault tolerance built in so it knows
when nodes go down or when data isn't
processed and it can actually rescale
the the cluster appropriately in
response to those faults it has parallel
ISM built in and it's separate from your
code so you don't change your code in
order to make your system more parallel
you just change the topology
configuration and your Python code
becomes more parallel it has guaranteed
message processing built in which I'll
cover more in a sec and it has some easy
code management and local development
features which we leverage so the storm
primitives that are built into the
framework are you typically start your
data processing system with a streaming
data set and actually we use Kafka for
this and almost everyone who uses storm
in production also uses Kafka for this
so we're going to cover Kafka in the
second half of the
explain like why that's a good tool for
that but typically you start with some
streaming data then zeromq is used under
the hood for IPC and bolts and spouts
are the core abstraction in storm a
spout is basically a process that
generates a stream of data and a bolt is
a process that actually works with that
stream of data and does some
transformation on it and that's
apologies laid out in a directed acyclic
graph and that graph is basically your
entire worker in Q system as like a
model of multistage processing then
there are some ops parts of storm like
the Nimbus and workers which manage
execution and then like I said you can
tune the parallelism and get fault
tolerance for free so why are topology
might look like this where on the left
you have the storm spout that's
generating data and then you might have
several storm bolts in this case the
directed graph is starting with two
bolts where the data splits out and then
a third bolt that's receiving data from
one of the two earlier bolts and all of
this is modeled in the topology storm
also has a notion of a tuple tree and
what that means is that it understands
the source of every piece of data that's
moving through your system so that if a
node goes offline in the middle of
processing some piece of data storm
knows where that data originated from
and is able to replay the original tuple
into your topology to reprocess that
data so in this example we start with a
sentence that sentence might move
through some bolts that do words
splitting and then those words might
actually be counted in the final tuple
is a word and the current count for that
word and the issue here is that storm
can efficiently know that if a bolt
while it was trying to count the word
cow for example falls over that actually
it needs to replay the sentence where
that word came from as well as any of
the other sentences that might have
contributed to that count and it's able
to do that very efficiently so I'm going
to show you a couple of code examples
now and then I'm actually going to jump
into the command line to show you the
project that we built that makes
deploying storm topologies really easy
with Python but I'm going to breeze
through the code first then I'll show it
to you from the terminal so basically
the two things you need to do in order
to use storm is that you need to write
your logic using some integration
library we've built one that's called
stream parse which we're going to show
you today and then you have to actually
describe the layout of your topology in
a domain-specific language that's built
for that purpose in this case the
language we're using is one that's
bundled with storm which is called the
closure DSO it's written in javas
closure like Lisp like programming
language but you don't really have to
know much about closure in order to use
it essentially you can see that it's
looks kind of like a Python dictionary
and it's basically saying I have a spout
that's called a word spout and that's
about corresponds to a file called word
spy and on the last line of this
definition is actually saying it emits
one tuple and that or it emits a tuple
with one field and that field is called
word right so that's all this is
basically saying if I implement that
spout in Python it looks something like
this and and basically in this toy
example here i'm just going to emit i
just create like an infinite stream of
words like dog cat zebra and elephant I
just admit those infinitely and that's
going to be my stream of word data that
I'm going to be counting because I guess
no big data example would be complete
without a word count example right so
the the word count bolt is only slightly
more complicated you basically tell the
bolt where it's getting is data in this
case that's actually the the word spout
that's over here right and then you
actually tell it ok this is the
implementation of my bolt these are the
two fields that I'm output in and then
here's something interesting I say p2
and what this means is I tell the
topology definition I want my bolt to
run with a process parallelism of 2 so
have to python processes that are
inputting data from the spout and that's
hinted here and then the word counter is
really simple it just maintains an
in-memory counter from the collections
API and it just counts every word and
not the at the very end it does two
things it emits the current count for
the word and it also logs it using
storms logging infrastructure
so I'm actually going to now jump into
the terminal and show this stuff to you
so let's see if this works yeah so far
so bad okay there we go so can you guys
read this all right yeah okay cool so I
so stream parse is a project that we
just open source today actually that
provides you with a command line utility
called s parse and s parse lets you
quick start a project which knows how to
run storm topologies and it'll also let
you run that storm topology from the
command line very quickly so
traditionally when people tried to play
with storm with Python they kind of got
turned off because you have to download
like all these Java dependencies and get
this cluster running on your machine and
it's a big pain but with s parse it's
actually really easy so you pip install
stream parse which is the library and
Python and then basically you get this
command and this command says s parse
QuickStart s parse run and then a few
other subcommands if I say s sparse
quick start and I create a directory
called PI data what happens is it
actually went ahead and created a bunch
of files that follow a directory
template that we have for how storm
topologies and java could be later sorry
storm topologies and Python could be
laid out and this actually relies on a
tool wonder the hood called line again
which is like a closure build tool but
it's kind of abstracted from you so you
don't really have to know about it
although that is a dependency for using
stream pars it's only one line of code
to install line again it's like either a
curl one liner or you know you could use
homebrew and install it and there's also
apt packages available but once you get
that running you can basically create
this topology this word count example in
the PI data directory and then i can run
sparse run s parse run and it'll
actually start running this word count
example from the command line what you
see in the bottom right here is i'm just
running a process monitor that's showing
that java has actually spun up and
that's because the storm infrastructure
is spinning up a local cluster right now
it's actually also compiling my topology
which
to find in that domain specific language
before and now that it's actually
running you'll see some Python processes
running on the right and so you'll
actually see that word count because
it's parallelism is to is running with
to python processes but then words was
running with one and and that's really
nice that kind of shows you kind of the
whole infrastructure running at the
command line and that's really all you
need to do to do local testing so as
another kind of cool example I created
just a slight variation of this project
where in addition to storing the or
sorry in addition to having a basic
quick started project i modified the the
bolt so that it actually stored data in
Redis so now basically instead of a
counter I'm just connecting to Redis and
then I'm incrementing doing something
like Z incur by in Redis to increment
the word count and if I run this guy
here I let's just do a sparse run again
now in the bottom left i'm actually
going to see the live word counts for
this topology and so you can actually
see that it's counting words really
quickly they're refreshing in that
screen that's just a Python one-liner
that's calling Redis and asking for the
sordid keys right and then the topology
went back down and so run this again and
the same thing happens so what's really
cool about stream parses not only does
it let you get storms started really
quickly and test these typologies
locally but it also sets up a structure
where you can organize your Python code
and deploy it to remote clusters and
actually what my teams working on right
now is making it really easy to do
things like manage virtual ends on
multiple storm machines that are running
in production which we have some code at
parsley that does that already so yeah
so that's basically stream parse you can
find it online at the same link as
before so let me see here let's pull
that back up cool and now i'm going to
hand it over to Keith who's going to
talk about organizing around blogs so
thank you Andrew yep so everyone I
assume can hear me okay so I want to
talk about organizing around logs and
the second half of the talk is about
Kafka but one of them
important things is sort of a shift in
the way that we've come to look at the
data that we process of parsley so the
question is what do I mean by logs you
know and I'm not talking about things
you'll send to log stash looking for you
know warnings about database queries
that are slow or system status messages
but what I'm really talking about is a
series of time-stamped facts about a
given system so you know the the example
that we do you know most of our
processing is based off of web logs that
we get you know where an analytics
company we get similar pixel data to
Google Analytics or omniture whoever so
we have a stream of data coming in
that's it's fundamentally a log but it's
also a raw data that needs to be
processed and as this goes through a
pipeline it eventually you know it gets
partially enriched or various stages
through the pipeline to the point where
it turns it to database operations and
depending on how you write this out you
could look at this as a series of logs
to be processed so when I say logs and
when I say a log oriented architecture
this is really what I'm talking about so
the motivation for this if anyone has
built a significantly sized distributed
system this looks painfully familiar to
those who haven't it might not look so
bad what happens is you start with one
system and then two systems need to talk
so those two systems get hooked together
then you need a monitoring system so
that gets connected to the monitoring
system and eventually you end up at this
lattice flat / spaghetti mess the
diagram taken from LinkedIn where every
system needs to talk to every other
system for various reasons so when you
organized around a unified log what you
have is you have a way for everyone to
talk to each other you have a basic
clearinghouse for all the information
that needs to be distributed around your
data center so you take the old diagram
and you make it much much simpler so now
everyone who needs to know about the
status of your system about what's going
on merely needs to basically tale dash F
the lock so that's obviously not
practical to run 37 tale processes on
each machine but you use a queuing
system or another system excuse me to
manage as a clear
a house for that data so needless to say
as I mentioned earlier we are most
decidedly a log centric organization we
were not built with that idea explicitly
it just sort of fell out of the problem
domain that we solve for and ironically
in this diagram the log is not central
to the diagram but is most certainly
central to our data processing you can
see it it's the second one down on the
left so and it was Andrew that actually
came up with this insight that when you
start thinking about our data and how we
work with it in terms of logs all of our
databases be it a real-time database or
archival data base the data isn't that
is not the canonical source of data the
only canonical source of data we
actually have are the raw web logs and
as long as we have those archived
everything else is functionally a
materialized view on that information
and once you realize that it's actually
kind of a freeing concept because you
don't have to worry about losing an
analysis because it can always be rima t
realized from you know your based
materials so the question of course is
what magical amazing system could
possibly handle all this data because as
you grow you know scaling is always a
problem and this is where a patchy Kafka
came in so it is it's from LinkedIn it's
a log centric messaging system it's
designed for incredibly efficient
resource usage now it solves a very
specific problem in its it's in a very
specific area because it's not quite a
messaging system it's not quite a pub
subsystem and it's not quite a log
aggregator like flume escribe it
basically does all three of them and it
doesn in a really interesting way with
some architectural trade-offs but what
is able to do is it's able to get really
kind of incredible throughput for us
personally we run it on three really
small machines in AWS but it's able to
handle the only bottleneck we have is
network throughput so when we need more
network throughput we add new machines
but in terms of disk in terms of memory
you know it's serving up tens of
thousands of messages per second with
virtually no load on our machines so and
also for note I guess Oh date is not a
new release at this point but it's also
able to have full replication of data
and your your data as it go
through as a vote eight so to go over
some quick concepts of Kafka you have a
cluster you have brokers within the
cluster this is a familiar architecture
it ends up feeling a little bit like
Cassandra where you have a ring
architecture where the topics themselves
are distributed among the are
distributed among the brokers based on
various rules you set in terms of
replication so within each broker we
have a topic and the topic is it's like
a pub sub topic it's what you produce to
it's what you consume to and for the
sake of replication it actually takes
that topic which is organized like a log
file and breaks it into partitions so
your topic might be named raw data but
it'll also have say ten partitions that
make their way around the rest of the
cluster so producer is pretty
straightforward produces messages
consumer groups you can actually
organize your consumers so that you
distribute the reading among several
machines so that it's guaranteed that
each message only reaches the consumer
wants so for handy distribution fault
tolerance and parallelization offsets I
will get to in just a moment but first
what's the catch right it sounds strange
new magical wonderful it's all of those
things but you know as adherence of the
cap theorem consistently consistency and
availability are great it does have some
issues with network partitioning but as
long as it's in the same data center
those are generally negligible the one
large architectural trade-off that it
makes which is a huge break from
traditional messaging systems is that
there is no out of order acknowledgement
of messages so and this is what i mean
by the offset on this slide to go back
so Kafka does not store message state on
a message per message basis instead what
it does true to its core as essentially
a distributed log is you store your
offset within that log so as a consumer
I know that I've read up to message 407
so I mark that as a mark I don't know if
I processed 406 405 if there was one
missed in there there's no way to
functionally store that within Kafka so
what it means is that you
it is again to go back to the analogy of
tail dash F on a log file it's very
similar to that on a restart you're
going to know where to pick up with in
that file because it is disk fact and
it's going to keep the data around for a
while so you know where to restart but
if there are little bits of missing
information behind there you're not
necessarily going to know that this
sounds like a really big problem this
sounds like a huge deficiency compared
to traditional messaging systems in
practice with a couple clever solutions
around batching and a little bit of care
it's actually proven to really not be a
problem for us at least with the kinds
of problems that we solve so again to go
over Kafka as the idea of a distributed
log it's because of how the partitions
work you have a log file split into
evenly sized pieces the consumers read
offsets into that log to get into one
technical detail the offsets are stored
on a partition basis so you wouldn't say
I've read up to message 146 on X
partition its or X topic its X topic y
partition but messages can be replayed
because it's all disk backed and logs
are maintained for a configurable period
of time and consumers share identical
logs easily so this is something that
compared to a lot of systems is a huge
difference so if you're using Regis's
pub/sub feature it needs to keep track
of every consumer it's blasting messages
out to if you're using RabbitMQ for
every consumer it stores message state
for every message and every consumer so
you know whether it's read whether it's
acknowledged failed retrying and all
that Kafka is a poll based system so in
fact prior to oda eight dot one it
didn't actually store those offsets you
were responsible for storing those
offsets in zookeeper or the client was
so really when you make a request from a
Kafka topic you're requesting X messages
from a certain from a certain topic /
partition it's entirely pull based so
what this does is this actually reduces
the load of what the kafka server needs
to keep track of and it's able to
paralyze to a number of consumers with
exceptionally small overhead
no duplication of messages there's no
duplication of state zookeeper whoever
might need to store more offsets but
those are generally integers and easily
stored so to revisit the idea of queuing
problems I alluded to this in the
previous slide rabbitmq and Redis have
serious shortcomings when dealing with
very high volume traffic so you can
scale a rabid mq cluster up to the size
that we need but it would take maybe an
order of magnitude or two more hardware
than we use right now and it's largely
because of these architectural
trade-offs like out of order
acknowledgments you know random disk
access is very very slow and especially
when you're talking about spinning disks
to have to go back and mark messages as
acknowledged as failed ends up putting a
huge amount of load on the system so and
again really the big thing is that more
consumers not leading to more server
load ends up in terms of scaling being
huge it means that you can add new
consumers for your data without ever
really having to worry about it you know
so if you have a new monitoring system
where you have whatever so this brings
us back around to the earlier bit about
storm and why the two are such a good
fit together you know and over the
evolution of storm there have been
various messaging systems that are in
vogue like casserole or Starling people
of you Stratos for messaging but by and
large Kafka is very popular in the storm
ecosystem today Andrew when he was
talking about the tubule trees and the
retrying so storms basic guarantee is at
least once processing for every tupple
not exactly once and there is ongoing
work in the community via project called
trident to bring guaranteed wants
processing but in general it provides at
least once guarantees so this really
fits in with Kafka's lack of out of
order acknowledgments since you don't
have a strong guarantee on the consuming
system the producing system doesn't need
the same strong guarantee and needless
to say if you have a system that's able
to produce millions of earth that's able
to process millions of tuples per second
it would be awfully nice to have a cue
system that could serve
millions of tuples per second and the
other thing that has come in really
handy for us is that when you have a
high-performance messaging system that
you can basically throw anything you
want at it without really having to
worry you can do all sorts of
interesting tricks so the one thing we
use it for are basically relief valves
within our pipeline so let's say one of
our database machines is sick you know
either went down or whatever and our
write throughput is suffering we have a
cut we have a we have a Kafka log right
in front of that right before it gets
written so that it doesn't shut down our
entire pipeline when that one area has a
problem you know you're able to
basically handle the back pressure from
that make sure that it doesn't knock
over systems further down the pipeline
and generally keep the real-time
processing system happy and healthy you
know we're in news analytics we deal
with very spiky data and its really nice
to be able to handle it in a same manner
without dying so this unfortunately I
don't have anything nearly as fancy is
Andrew to show but there are two current
Python drivers for Kafka 14 081407 the
reason I bring up the two given that 07
is a bit older is that this one
currently does not support the fancy
distributed consumer stuff I was talking
about where they share partitions this
one's much simpler 408 called Kafka
Python this 140 dot 7 which is the one
we use and the one we maintain has the
enhanced consumer which it uses
zookeeper for coordination between nodes
and if any wants to come up afterwards I
can go into the details about it but
that's why I bring up the two drivers
it's worth noting depending on what you
need there's no real need in the
community for two drivers so hopefully
as we migrated as a company to 0 dot 8
will be able to merge the two
communities and keep things reasonable
needs to say this whole log centric
thing is not necessarily our idea a lot
of other companies are involved you know
have the same way of thinking about the
data that they process most notably
linkedin had a great blog post on log
centric architectures they create a
Kafka
of course as Andrew mentioned above back
type which created store so in
conclusion what we've learned it goes
without saying that there's no silver
bullet and data processing technology
for me I think having a high-throughput
messaging system has changed the way I
think about a lot of problems but it
doesn't necessarily solve all of them it
just makes life a lot easier you know
the other nice thing about logged log
centric architecture is that disk space
is really really cheap so if you think
about that as your principal data store
you know you're not as worried about as
long as you can make it queryable in the
end it's not as much of a focus on the
memory heavy systems so timestamp facts
in there Ross form our great source of
data storm and Kafka both let you
develop on top of them so we have a fair
bit of time left there any questions I
don't know if we have a mic going around
so I've been we're a company that's
pretty heavily invested on AWS and it
sounds like you guys are as well so why
would I choose Kafka over something like
Kinesis which seems like it fulfills
very the requirements are almost exactly
in the limitations and like it almost
exactly the same except I don't have all
the overhead in the complexity of like a
zookeeper setup and that sort of stuff
is there something that coffee gives me
that Kinesis doesn't so it ends up being
a similar question too why do I roll
post grass instead of redshift it's
usually a question of cost in terms of
features I personally haven't
investigated Kinesis yeah so much
initiative so Kinesis actually basically
imitated the kafka api and was coming I
out around the same time that Kafka was
getting popular so like Keith said it's
a question of do you want to lock
yourself in to you know the Amazon
infrastructure or do you want to run
open source software on your own
hardware or your own virtual machines
that's really all it comes down to yeah
yes I think they both scratch the itch I
don't know exactly in the weeds like
what Kinesis has that Kafka doesn't I
haven't done like that analysis but I
know that they're very kind of similar
philosophically you know yeah one of the
things that's really nice about trying
to is that you basically specify your
topology in a very functional way and
and then it sort of computes the
physical execution plan for you do you
guys have any plans for stream parts to
do something like that with your closure
definitions or no so we've started
looking into it there's a jira ticket
open on storm to get multilang support
for trident barring that we can't really
do a whole lot because you know it's
very heavily tied to the the JVM and all
that but that's certainly you know as we
as we work on stream parts that's
definitely something we're going to be
looking into because it really does seem
like Trident is the direction that
storms moving for pretty much everything
Keith can you talk a little bit about
some of the overhead costs you might
incur on switching over from a non log
base 10 system to a log based system and
either some of the scales of which it
becomes appropriate or some of the
strategies you might use to accomplish
that uh certainly I mean for us it was
it was very much changing the way we
looked at the problem we had we didn't
actually make a lot of huge
architectural changes when we first
started looking at it this way we're
starting to as we move down the road I
think one of the better examples is you
know we do a lot of web scraping and
storing logs for that instead of just
ephemeral data in the database would be
really nice I got the cost they big the
big win you get I guess if you're
switching if you're kind of switching
mindset is that you start treating your
databases like pure indexes and not like
databases so that also means that if
you're evaluating all these newer
databases that have different trade-offs
it's very easy for you to basically run
two systems and pero el that are both
like computing similar views but on
different database technologies of your
original log data and if you treat your
database as like the canonical store
then that might be like a painful schema
migration problem yeah so it's much more
of a conceptual change than
architectural one for us so specific
changes one would make you know as long
as you're storing all your broad data in
a very raw format wouldn't be huge yeah
in terms of like scale i guess i don't
know i think that it probably comes down
to you know if you're doing thousands of
messages per second and you feel like
back pressure on of RabbitMQ instance or
overflow on your reticence tins is like
imminent and you're starting to
investigate things like how to
distribute out Redis using some of the
newer stuff that's available you might
you know be at the right scale where
maybe you should look at Kafka instead
right but if a single RabbitMQ instance
is serving your whole plant fine then
that's fine you know so
where where did you build your message
resiliency means the fault tolerance if
something breaks during the transition
so so so there are three parts of the
question so that's what part and output
all the three-second is how complex is
your logic in the middle tier which is
in at the strong processing so complex
even processing place and then what are
the other end persistency model did you
use it was it Hadoop based or any other
database or because when I see so many
messages coming in the pipeline you must
have interesting implementation for
purchase that data so that okay so all
right so to take that from the first
part most of our redundancy for the
actual log collection and persistence to
Kafka is handled by Kafka itself so our
data collectors write directly to the
kafka instance and then we rely on
Kafka's replication for the actual
persistence and resiliency there as far
as the actual complexity of the storm
topologies you know we have two
topologies that run in sequence with a
Kafka queue in between I mean I don't I
don't know how to evaluate complexity I
mean I I built it I feel it was complex
but that feels like a very subjective
evaluation to me but as far as the data
persistence goes that was actually a
really interesting problem for us so our
principal data store is [ __ ] DB we
really appreciate the query ability a
lot of things work but write throughput
isn't the best in the world you know if
this was Cassandra the story would have
been a lot simpler but with MongoDB we
had to worry a lot about overflowing it
especially when we were running on
smaller instances we used to swamp them
all the time so this was actually where
we put actually put a Kafka instance
right in front of where we write to the
database so it was basically writing out
MongoDB zop log to Kafka before I got to
[ __ ] at which point we could take all
those operations and reduce them so we
do a lot you know we're analytic
company we do a lot of adding one and
one a lot so you take all those
operations you reduce them to their most
information efficient form and you end
up reducing the number of operations
that are actually sent to [ __ ] at last
count I think we had 100 to 1 efficiency
on that so we produced you know a
hundred thousand we ended up only
writing one thousand that you don't in
storm you don't have the acknowledgement
method to tell sender that I have
processed the message completely you do
yeah you do I'm doing that okay oh yeah
so it's part it's part of both the
multilang protocol and the core storm
API that you can acknowledge that a
tuple has been a processed or you can
fail a tuple and in that case it will
replay the tuple from the tuple trees
root if you fail it no matter where in
the topology you fail it right then give
them how is Dom support for breaking
down a complex task into subtasks
dependence of dust and executing them on
the distributed infrastructure that's a
great question so the question was how
storms support for breaking big tasks
into subtasks that you can like kind of
work on reasonably and and actually
that's one of the big wins we've gotten
out of storms so for example when we do
teamwork on data flows like these we
often break up our project by thinking
about the inputs and outputs of
different bolts inside a storm topology
and we have different engineers working
on different bolts and testing them in
isolation before wiring them together in
a topology and what's really wonderful
about this is that no engineer has to
really worry about you know how it's
going to run concurrently in practice
and no individual engineer has to worry
about like you know message
acknowledgement and replay and failed
you know all of this kind of stuff and
not to mention monitoring and all of the
rest of it instead that code gets tested
in isolation and when you wire a
topology together you actually have like
a complete data processing pipeline but
each component is kind of on its own so
I think it actually does really help
with teamwork on some of these streaming
data problems
kind of is the right level of
abstraction for that
anyone else we all sit there we go hi um
with Kafka what's the the mechanism for
actually getting data out of your
program into the log is that is that
like socket level what's the options and
what's the performance profile of that
am I waiting while the right is
happening and so on so there are a
number of ways to do this it's gotten
better with the ODA a release what they
do is they implement they implement
their own binary TCP protocol so it's
not HTTP rest or any of that which ends
up giving you a little bit more
efficiency at the expense of you know
driver writers like myself have to
implement a binary interface there are a
bunch of things in terms of bursting
communication so one of the big things
when you're writing out lines they're
very small and it results in a lot of
small transmissions which are remarkably
inefficient over TCP so there are in a
properly amended driver batching
mechanisms so that you're sending fewer
larger messages to the kafka broker it
does the same thing on the back end when
sending messages back so in general
throughput we've seen I mean we do and
again we run by all measures are a
pretty small cluster it handles I think
20,000 messages per second which for us
translates to and get 75 megabits in
about 160 megabits out so and that's not
I mean those machines are really under
loaded so we've been we've actually been
ramping up how much we use Kafka because
we have so much we're so over proficient
yeah I understand that you you're down
sampling before you store in one would
you be hmm what makes sense for you if
there were a use case where you wanted
to preserve all of the logs intact to
dump them into something like
elasticsearch so you could then preserve
the entire data so we actually do keep
all the logs we store them in s3 and
Amazon s3 and then we use traditional
Hadoop tooling to do batch processing
over the logs so you know part of the
log centric infrastructure is that the
log data comes in it gets backed up
right away so we can rebuild from it at
any moment but then the live stream of
data moves through the storm processing
plant and real time computation happens
from there and yeah you're right that
you know technologies like elastic
search I don't think we've actually
played with elastic search and it
wouldn't really work to send all of our
logs into elasticsearch or at least we'd
have to run a really massive
elasticsearch cluster to make that
happen but you could do a little
aggregation and then put data in a
source like that and it would work
pretty well yeah all right let's give a
round a plus to Andrew and Keith
by the way quickly